[Music]
in smartphone bone news what you
submitted by staking shakes humans have
started growing spikes in the back of
their skulls wheels was probably the
y'all you miss young you may be a start
texting like this because I'm always
watching the posture it is from the
posture so what's happening is that our
bodies are compensating for the extra
weight weight that happening but you're
doing this yeah so that like right here
in the back of your school Richard yeah
people are growing like a little spike
so it looked like this returning it's a
dinosaur real real oh what is the bone
what is that part it's trying to balance
balance the way much weight going
forward so it's trying to get away for
your head back
it's growing to like balance the weight
this is like x-men you know to me yeah
the mutation is finally how I'm gonna
get like Spike accessories like head
spikes just like a bone spur is that
what this is it seems like it right I
don't know the whole time okay so
scientists from the University of the
Sunshine Coast in Australia they don't
sound reputable it does sound like an
online university they also do gambling
it's offshore gambling and at university
yeah so they are saying that they found
in their study that because of heavy use
of smartphones and handheld devices
there have been an increasing number of
young people with this unusual did call
it above the bony spur an unusual bony
spur you called it yeah even know what
it was it just sounded like it was
buspar yeah it's not like where it's
like stressed I don't I'm not a medical
professional but where it's like
stressed and then extra calcium starts
to try to mmm make it stronger
yeah like you know when you break a bone
are you asking that guy that didn't know
there was two holes on the cheeks but
just true nevermind I have a BS okay
yeah [ __ ] there's two two holes on
the chicks are diary through and there's
a vagina oh okay well then that's not
your okay no no you guys I know I'm
right where's that other hole like this
three holes in the pink one in the oh
yeah we don't we don't count the pee
hole is like a hole you didn't know he
thought the whole you [ __ ] that's
what I thought oh you're just an idiot
yeah so you can't you can't refer to a
part that's the only thing I don't know
you know but you don't tell me what a
bone spur is then cuz I wait wait a
minute wait for grown calcified that's
what I just told you if you thought that
I nice pill [ __ ] me that's love no but
yeah okay all right
yeah that was my I was curious like it
still that is but where the urethra is
still dere right we're the it's like
clothes like it's right there is it near
like is it on the top or the bottom you
know you get your Taurus with your okay
right have you ever found a clitoris Wow
yeah yes I'm very good yeah well then
you found the people oh there you go so
we all like pee pee I guess we all do
actually I'm sorry I'll be eating all
right so we set your people I mean not
yours that's actually true though what
are we saying yeah because I did it
someone for the dudes
so that bone it's called an external
occipital protuberance and so they that
right people are just making up words
we're still thinking about them we're
all still thinking about pee holes right
yeah for two parents okay all right
going alright so they looked at 218
radiographs of the lateral cervical
spine cervical where the well cervical
means neck in it yeah yes that's the
cervix your cervix your cervix it's the
neck of your uterus this is your neck
like over your cervix of your head yes
cervical so they found that people aged
between 18 to 30 years old had a growth
to be at least five millimeters long
that's pretty long yeah bigger than 10
millimeters classified as enlarged I
mean that's a long that sticking out
what you have one I think I do it's a
little love oh let me see over here
right here my fingers are I don't have
it
no that's when you get into a fight or
something each other but do you guys
know everything nada
thank you I think of it I think it's it
yeah it goes in its the younger people
I'm gonna get an x-ray I think we're all
too old good I just really feel like a
little like it was like this everyone's
here over 30 right no not her best way
she 29 30 30 is coming up that's when
he's gonna leave you know I did no no he
didn't nod that he's not gonna leave her
you will leave me you just you just you
anyway you got to put her down man which
is thirsty huh I guess we're all dead I
know I'm the youngest one here what are
you talking about I know I get it
I don't think I don't think everybody's
old or she looks young but you do look
very young hey good for you you don't ha
got you back
someone's back to when you were like
sucking on my
let's get back to that that was better
don't victim blame all right so of that
group 41 percent had the lump and ten
percent so you're part of the forty I am
throwing tails but on our head it is you
might think you have cancer or something
like how do you not you know what I mean
how do you have a cell phone bump I'm
gonna feel every one of your guys do it
do it ten minutes the feeling of you
nails though cuz I'm literally pushing
it right now I think all of our skulls
hardened before we were heavy into our
phones and yours wasn't hardened yet cuz
I was too young
no just kidding nice so they're saying
here that what was it okay so ten
percent had a spike at least twenty
millimeters long and it was more common
in men than women wow that makes sense
sixty-seven percent versus twenty
percent and then the longest thought
they found was thirty five point seven
millimeters in a man I know why I know
why a man and more than me too
because women are doing this all the
time this is my angle
thinking the men because they're just
always watching porn on their phone yeah
you know a women watch porn on their
phones too yeah we're like watching porn
like this I take it all back not
wholesome at all it took you a few hours
yeah this is crazy
yeah I'm on the freeway you don't even
know that's preposterous
level zero car watch all the videos
sorry they don't come out and order
either but anyway yeah so they're
they're describing this phenomenon as
text neck and so text Nick they've been
talking about that sounds like a
restaurant in town oh yeah
so now they're just saying you know this
just be mindful let's be mindful of what
do know we're adapting okay this is in
Buckner it's gonna happen where we just
have contacts as the phone and then we
just look at me like it's from here and
they will not know but I think we don't
have a look at people and then will I
see information
exactly that'd be cool so you know it's
a contact it's not like it's not like
brain implant I'll be terrible and what
if I get said like you know big thing I
looked at you it says like crazy chick
hoe you know no Chola you know what yeah
right oh my god
so it was like they have to give you a
certain amount of legs and then it
depends on what car we're almost there
on that one anyway yeah we're almost
there I would you know like without with
the uber ratings and all that kind of
stuff we're already there yeah the one
that scared me on black Mara was the one
where like you could like you have that
implant where you could like yeah yeah
it was crazy because the dude was right
she did she yeah but if you didn't have
that thing then he could have like just
saved himself
yeah oh I thought it was terrible to
that they were like having sex with each
other but they was from my preview yeah
yeah or the one where the mom implanted
that thing and the girls always like
censored for her whole life yeah things
that one's real bad yeah Alice [ __ ] you
know that show makes me feel bad like I
don't want to watch that [ __ ] our yeah
sure she watches friends it feels bad
friends I don't watch frying something
what do you watch then that makes me
feel good stories
what is the one she just said she liked
watching and we were all like 20 light
that's right in another video right now
we're done with this video just fine
read all the videos and you can like
could you know do this though bring it
all together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]